canceled culture is coming for the whole
state of georgia
the peach state under fire over a
controversial new voting law
signed by the governor last week
organizations are now demanding that
major league baseball all-star games
and the masters change locations under
protest
the movement is being met with
resistance from none other than bernice
king
the daughter of martin luther king jr
who says that the georgia boycott
would hurt middle-class workers and
people grappling with poverty
increasing the harm of both racism and
classism
here now is the man who signed the bill
into law just a few days ago georgia
governor
brian kemp welcome governor thank you so
much for joining us tonight
good to be with you thank you so i can't
think of anything more important
than securing our elections and
restoring confidence which i think so
many people have lost
um especially over this last year tell
our viewers what you think this new
georgia bill
do to restore confidence in georgia's
elections well it's very simple it makes
it easy to vote and hard to cheat
really the four main things that i just
want to make sure that people realize
what the bill does it takes the
the signature match process and replaces
it with the voter id which is free in
georgia
it secures drop boxes in
a better way than was done in the last
election
also requires poll workers to
continuously count or tabulate the
ballots until every vote is counted
and then it expands access for our early
voting period especially on the weekends
as you know democrats are raging mad
about this bill they say your bill is
racist
what do you say that they are objecting
to what do you perceive that to be
i mean look it's just a talking point i
don't know how anybody could honestly
read the facts
behind this bill and what the bill does
it's providing more access with weekend
voting
is securing drop boxes that never were
allowed in
elections in georgia before this year
and that was only done through an
emergency order so it codifies that in
the law the democrats act like
we're taking something away because we
just want to secure
the drop boxes inside the polling
locations
and it's doing a lot of other things
that mechanically
were issues during the election with how
long it took to count all the votes
that's really
what's behind the voter id piece on
absentee ballots by mail
it removes an arbitrary process it was
very cumbersome for local
elections official workers i've talked
to them
the the photo id or voter id requirement
will speed that process up
uh takes away you know the arbitrary
nature of a signature match
that's done by multiple people and
things of that nature of course
the other side they they don't care
what's in the bill this
narrative has been thought out long
before they even knew
what was going to be in the final
version and if you look at the debate
that's happened over the last several
weeks
you know their narrative has changed of
what they were against and what they're
now against
it's uh you know now really come down to
water and whether you're taking water
away from people that are standing in
line and that's not the case either
that's just not true
so do you think that the businesses in
georgia are gonna
you know collapse or or succumb to the
pressure
from the left in terms of this boycott
and how will that affect georgia
i don't believe that they will i mean i
agree with bernice king it's it's wrong
for people especially a lot of these
activists from out of state that are
benefiting financially from pushing this
narrative
to punish to punish hard-working
georgians
great institutions like the masters and
major league baseball and other things
in our state that by the way
employ a lot of hard-working georgians
that are trying to fight through
this this pandemic yeah well the two
senators in your state are supporting
that boycott it's a really interesting
way to support georgia
um governor thanks so much for joining
us tonight
thank you take care